javier becerra was born in sacramento
california
to two working-class immigrants from
mexico
at the time becerra and his family of
six squeezed into a 685 square foot home
near hugh stadium about 60 years later
the secretary of health and human
services owns more than three million
dollars in real estate
becerra graduated from stanford in 1980
before receiving a law degree from the
same school just four years later
after graduating becerra briefly moved
to massachusetts while his wife carolina
reyes studied medicine at harvard
soon after he returned to the west coast
and joined california state senator
art torres team in 1986.
after a brief stint as deputy attorney
general in the state civil division
becerra won election to california state
assembly in 1990
earning the title of rising star from
the los angeles times
but he did not stay long after u.s house
member edward roybel announced his plans
to retire
becerra made a bid for congress and won
when he arrived in washington becerra
started with a 133
600 salary the standard for all members
of congress at the time
over the next 24 years he became a power
player in washington
and secured a federal pension worth more
than 750 thousand dollars
but in 2016 when kamala harris's senate
election
opened the door for a new california
attorney general becerra pounced on the
opportunity
he was selected for the role and packed
his bags for a return to california
the new job saw him earn 170 000 in 2017
and prompted his family to sell their
home in chevy chase maryland for 1.6
million dollars
and buy a new place in sacramento for
955 000
the next year the family sold a condo in
washington dc's capitol hill
for two hundred and ninety thousand
dollars and purchased two more
properties in sacramento
a townhouse for four hundred and sixty
thousand dollars and a three bedroom for
527 thousand dollars
both of which they started renting out
unsurprisingly
real estate is a major asset in basara's
fortune
he's also rented two other homes in los
angeles worth about 575 thousand dollars
and 1.4 million dollars and received at
least 60 000
in rental income in 2020. his properties
comprise about half
of his seven million dollar net worth
the cabinet member also has about 1.5
million dollars in retirement in other
investment accounts
and 1.1 million dollars in two
government pensions
today as secretary of health and human
services becerra earns more than two
hundred thousand dollars
while his wife continues to work in her
field of maternal fetal medicine
you